Amber Heard has gone nude on film before
but when it came time to go toddlers for
2018's London Fields she flat out
refused and consequently was sued by
producers for 10 million dollars based
on a novel of the same name the film
stars heard as Nikola 6 a clairvoyant
Femme Fatale who predicts she'll be
murdered by one of her three lovers
given both the script and the novel it
was based on contained nude scenes
producers argued that herd was well
aware she'd be asked to go nude
producers argued that her unwillingness
to strip for the film severely disrupted
the production and that she tried to
pull the film from the Toronto
International Film Festival lineup in
2015. the production company Nikolas 6
limited sued heard for 10 million
dollars or about 40 times what London
Fields eventually made at the domestic
box office when it was finally released
in 2018. it's 250 000 take makes it one
of the biggest bombs in history